[Music]
foreign
so this is another video in our review
of calculus especially the Taylor series
and here I'm going to do one of my
favorite examples this is a really
really neat example so we're literally
going to write down the Taylor series
for f of x equals the exponential of X
and I'm going to show you that you can
use this uh this Taylor series to
actually derive the cosine and sine
functions using you can derive Euler's
function and this is going to be super
important in differential equations
complex analysis this is going to come
up everywhere in math and in applied
math so I kind of like this this example
okay so the Taylor series in the last
lecture I showed you how to derive this
you know f of x is approximately F at
zero plus F Prime at zero times X Plus F
double Prime at zero times x squared
over two factorial dot dot dot you can
write this out I'm just going to write
out what the Taylor series is for e to
the X maybe I'll write it above my head
so I don't chop my head off e to the x
is going to be I should remember this uh
off the top of my head
is one
plus X
plus x squared over 2 factorial
plus x cubed over 3 factorial plus x to
the fourth over 4 factorial plus x to
the fifth over five factorial
um I probably don't need to go that high
I'll just say plus dot dot dot plus
higher order terms terms in you know x
to the sixth seventh eighth higher order
terms and the generic term I'm going to
say this is the sum
from let's say am I using index K I'll
say k
equals 0 to Infinity
of x to the power k
over K factorial
this is probably the most important
Taylor series you can remember so you
know what I'm going to ask you to do
this is a really good exercise for you
is
write down the actual so this is
technically a McLaren series because
we're kind of expanding about x equals
zero so it's a Taylor series expanded
about x equals zero you can use the
formula I gave you in the last lecture
for the Taylor series and you can verify
that this is exactly what you get when
you compute you know
e to the 0 is 1. the first derivative of
e is you know e to the x is also e to
the X and so on and so forth and you can
get that these are all of the
coefficients for this uh this this
Taylor series or maclaurin series
expansion so that's a homework exercise
for you is to verify that this is true
but I'm just writing it down and if
someone shakes you awake in the middle
of the night on a desert island
um you know two in the morning you
should first of all probably be able to
write this down you know out of memory
if you are an engineer or a scientist
it's so important but even more
important than that is you should be
able to be to like derive this from
first principles using kind of your
definition of a Taylor series okay but
that's not uh exactly what I want to
show you what I want to show you is how
you can use this expression to derive
Euler's formula which is really really
neat okay so we're going to write I'm
also going to write this in yellow and
I'm going to try not to chop my head off
again so now if we take
e to the i x let's say we plug in a
complex number so X is real let's say we
plug in an imaginary number e to the i x
this is going to get interesting and
this doesn't have to be just purely
imaginary this can actually be a full-on
complex number but we're just going to
say e to the i x
and I'm literally every place here where
I see an X I'm going to replace it with
an i x
so that's going to equal
1 plus I X
plus i x squared over 2 factorial plus I
X
cubed over 3 factorial plus I X to the
fourth over 4 factorial I'm going to
write it up to fifth i x to the fifth
over 5 factorial plus dot dot dot so on
and so forth forever
and here's where it gets interesting now
you know anytime I have an i squared
that's a real number again anytime I
have an i to an odd power I'm going to
have an I pop out so let me just write
this out and we'll collect all of our
terms this equals one
plus I X
I squared is minus 1. so this is minus
x squared over 2 factorial
I cubed is minus I so this is minus I
x cubed over 3 factorial
I to the fourth is one again so this is
Plus
x to the fourth over 4 factorial I to
the fifth is we're going back to I so
this is plus I X to the fifth over 5
factorial and it's going to repeat my um
my my x to the sixth is going to be a
minus x to the 6 over 6 factorial then
minus i x to the seventh over seven
factorial plus x to the eighth over
eighth factorial and so on and so forth
forever and ever plus dot dot dot
and so what's kind of cool now is I can
I I notice that all of my even powers of
X my x to the 0 x to the two x to the
four x to the sixth don't have any eyes
out front all of my eyes canceled
because they were squared or taken to
the fourth power or the sixth power
so all of my even Powers here don't have
an i
want to write those in pink
and all of my odd terms do have an i my
my x to the one power has an i my X
cubed has an i my x to the fifth has an
i x to the seventh and Ninth and
eleventh are all going to have eyes
because those are not canceling out
and so I can actually group this into my
even powers that don't have an eye and
all of my odd powers that do have an eye
so I'm going to write that out this
equals
and let's start
with all of my uh my even Powers so this
equals one minus x squared over 2
factorial plus x to the fourth over 4
factorial minus x to the sixth over six
factorial plus dot dot dot that's all of
my terms with no eyes with no imaginary
part
and now I'm going to write down all of
my uh my X terms plus all of these have
an imaginary part
and I have X
minus x cubed over 3 factorial Plus
x to the fifth over five factorial minus
and plus and dot dot dot forever and
ever
and here's where it gets really
interesting you should recognize now
from you know the previous lecture this
is the Taylor series for cosine and this
is the Taylor series for sine so this
literally equals this is cosine of x
and this whole thing here with the eye
and everything is I
sine of x
and so this is Euler's formula one of
the most important formulas in all of
math it's a really beautiful formula is
that e to the i x is equal to
cosine of x
plus I sine of x
and this is going to come up and be
useful all the time when we solve
differential equations so when we solve
a differential equation uh you know x
dot equals
Lambda X we know that the solution of
this is going to be something like X of
T equals e to the Lambda T times my
initial condition X naught what if my
eigenvalue sorry I'm saying eigenvalue I
haven't told you what an eigenvalue is
yet but what if this Lambda is an
imaginary number this is going to happen
for real physical systems for things
like a mass on a spring anything that
has oscillation or a pendulum we're
going to find that we're going to write
those differential equations in terms
like this where this is now an imaginary
or a complex number and so I'm going to
need to be able to take e to an
imaginary number and write it down in
terms of its cosine and sine component
which is kind of going to make sense
because if I have an oscillating Mass on
a spring or if I have a pendulum that's
oscillating of course that's going to be
described by periodic oscillating
functions cosine and sine so this is
going to come up a lot in our Solutions
of differential equations if that was a
little fast that's okay this is like the
whole next week of this this course is
all talking about you know how to do
this for for real and imaginary lambdas
and where that comes into physical
systems
but for now I just want to point out
that with Taylor series you can do
really powerful things like you can
derive uh
Euler's formula
and again I'm going to you know
emphasize anything with Euler's name is
a big deal so don't forget Euler's
formula this is really really really
important okay good
I really
facile with
kind of computation
and start getting really comfortable
going back and forth from you know
cosines and Sines and ease to their
various power series because we're going
to use this a lot okay okay thank you
[Music]